what happens when you introduce scp-914  to one of the world's first computer  viruses dr manheim prepared one usb  drive with a text file containing the  source code of the computer virus  creeper no organic materials were used  for the test out of concern for  potentially biohazardous effects a  hazmat team was placed on standby for  the duration of the experiment the  infected usb drive was placed into the  clockworks on the setting very fine the  output produced was a metallic green  figure with a cylindrical shape as soon  as it was removed from scp-914 the  object self-destructed in a manner  resembling an ordinary firework all in  all the experiment was extremely  anti-climactic and a bit disappointing